nos véhicules.
Philippe Leblanc.
- C'est un des plus
grands rassemblements de
l'industrie du semi-conducteur :
le salon SEMICON.
Plus de 700 exposants
y présenteeueueurs plus
récentes innovations.
C'est l'occasion pour
les entreprises de partout de
brasser des affaires à Taïwan,
plus grand producteur mondial
dans le domaine.
Cette édition de SEMICON
a lieu au moment où l'industrie
taïwanaise tente de se faire
rassurante. L'incertitude plane
en raison de la menace
d'une invasion de Tawawawan
par la Chine.
Taïwan produit plus de 90 %
de toutes les micropuces
les plus avancée m m monde.
Ces semi-conducteurs, aussi
petits que deux nanomètres
dans certains cas, sont
essentiels en informatique
et téléphonie cellulaire,
ainsi que dans les transports
et la défense.
La sécurité de Taïwan
est njnjnjeu important pour
les États-Unis, qui veulent
assurer leurs approvisionnements
de micropuces, selon cet expert.
Il rappelle que les Américains
ont adopté une loi pour
relancer leur propre production.
Ils cherchent à former
des partenariats avec
les entreprises taïwanaises,
dont le géant mondial TSMC.
Parallèlement, la Chine cherche
aussi à augmenter sa production.
Mais certains craignent
que ça reste un motif
pour envahir Taïwan.
"Même s'ils s'emparaient de nos
usines, affirme ce dirigeant,
ils n'auraient pas acc
à notre expertise."
♪ ♪ ♪
Risque d'invasion, augmentation
de la production en Chine,auauÉi
en Europe : des pressions
immenses pour une industrie
déjà frappée par une pénurie
de travailleurs qualifiés.
Avec l'arrivée de la 5G,
l'industrie des semi-conducteurs
est plus indispensable que
jamais, ce qui fait de l'avenir
de Taïwan un enjeu stratégique
de premier ordre.
Ici Phillippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Taipe